three parking spot calm I'm very
delighted to be joined by Alex Amancio
credit writer on Assassin's Creed unity
so this is a game that I watched I feel
like the Parisien thing has been a leak
that has existed in the video game
community for it for years now
like the result before Black Flag came
out there is always are they gonna go to
revolutionary France Paris and finally
now what we're seeing we're seeing unity
and for folks who haven't seen a judge
just give this sort of set the scene for
where Assassin's Creed unity is take
place all right essentially unity takes
place in Paris the reason we chose Paris
was because we were you know for this
first iteration of assassin suite it's
fully next-gen we really wanted to go
back to the basics so large sprawling
urban area we looked at many cities and
we quickly fell upon Paris I mean Paris
is the most visited city in the world
there's literally a landmark at every
corner so we decided very early on that
Paris is going to be the the place but
when in Paris that was a real question
so we started looking at you know what
the next generation bring us in terms of
breakthroughs and you know assassin
speed is all about social stealth
massive crowds when can we find large
massive crowds in Paris French
Revolution yeah yeah I was almost like
watching lame is the video game it's
either you're walking up the barricade
yeah yeah so in terms of Paris itself
that different places you go to is like
sacre coeur and not your damn purse I
like where are the touchstones it will
be visiting most Parisian landmarks that
existed at that time
so like the Eiffel Tower obviously
wasn't in 18th century Paris but all of
the landmarks are there we do have her
saw it we even have the village around
Versailles so are you saying okay sounds
like the Eiffel Tower is going to be the
ultimate synchronization points I'm
guessing you're gonna be able to get to
the top of it and oh if it existed in
the 18th century we would excellent ok
so this is the you showed off a bunch of
stuff actually on conference day you
showed off the CG trailer and you also
showed off quite a long gameplay segment
as well and what what are we looking at
here this is the CG trailer what we
trying to get across in this trailer all
right this trailer really focuses on
what the inception of the French
Revolution the beginning this is the
piece that FSC this is one the Parisian
population hungry famished poor took up
arms
took possession of the best see a symbol
for you know the corrupt nobility and
they exempted the reason they stormed it
was actually to steal gunpowder that was
stashed inside and this is what you're
seeing here at the end is that
essentially that the governor of the
bass see this guy that we're seeing here
he was and this is historical apparently
he was threatening to ignite the powder
and blow everything away and so the idea
is the assassins let the population do
their you know what they were gonna do
all they did was safeguard you know
prevented the governor from destroying
the gunpowder yeah that the population
could have it so that there seems to be
a theme between both this and the
gameplay you showed Oh the assassins not
necessarily casting it taking out this
I'm sorry carrying out your sash they
show themselves but actually throwing
the victim to the crowd and letting them
have their way with it is that is is
that a theme because that seems to be a
theme of what revolutionary France was
as well if you think a better price of
our rope spirits the first yeah and you
shouldn't we have some of that in the
game you obviously get to assassinate
characters but the crowd is you know we
have three factions in the game we have
the protectors these are the guards
they're cops they're gonna keep the
balance within the city their role is to
keep order we have aggressors these are
they're represented by rebel
revolutionary sort of extremists these
are gonna you know be provoking people
and the player throughout the game you
know just walk around systemic lee in
the crowd and then the crowd is the
third fashions some people are armed and
they will react to certain situations
they will take part in the action so
it's a bit what we're seeing here and I
mean we show two demos yesterday right
we showed the the single player one that
focus on the systemic world and we show
the co-op one that essentially show the
co-op experience and if you notice in
the first one and the first one we show
the co-op one the theme was the title of
the of the of that demo was the dawn of
the revolution it's set in 1789 and
you're essentially killing and Noble but
if you look at the second it's set in
1793 it's called the title as the reign
of terror and you're actually killing an
official so the revolution changes a lot
in four years and we're actually
following that throughout the game the
Assassin's Creed franchise many of these
games have spanned quite a long period
of time and are you going to do
something similar here
well for you to be we yes we are gonna
spend I'm not gonna go into too many
details because I don't want to spoil it
but but but we will spend quite a few
decades that there's going to be a this
story is is quite epic and the
protagonist in these series have often
have been the touchstone of where the
people like they're not you know no
there's some games where people don't
care who they play as where as the
reaction to say the Connor
it invokes it shows you how much people
want to connect with them we tell us to
the benefit at the protagonist in
Assassin's Creed unity who who is he and
then where's his he's for prison so
you're essentially playing a guy called
Arno Arno is uh you know his mother was
Austrian his father's French that's why
he has that name Arno is is a dramatic
name it means eagle so that convenient
so that he owned all tire also mean
either
so essentially our nose quest is one of
redemption he feels responsible for an
event that happened to him he lost his
father and he feels responsible for that
and the assassins you know he joins the
assassins because they're sort of a
means to obtaining that Redemption
what's cool about it is that our nose
narrative actually has him learning what
it truly is what it truly means to be an
assassin
and players are going to be experiencing
that with our know so at the same time
we're also introducing the assassins to
the fans in a new light because
Assassin's Creed unity you know because
it is the first truly next-gen iteration
you know completely next generation of
the franchise we really wanted to take
this opportunity to sort of start with a
new beginning not that we're you know
erasing everything that happened not at
all Assassin's Creed is always canon but
you know the franchises started back in
2007 and it's very narrative heavy and
typically it's always good at one point
to sort of start anew you know not only
for new fans but even for the the
long-running fence and assassin suite
unity is a new beginning and Arno will
sort of reflect that new beginning
because you will be discovering the
assassins and the Templars through his
eyes excellent and so to that end then
and another staple of the franchise has
been the interaction with the animus and
the secondary story that's happening are
you guys going to include any of that in
unity at all yeah the the there's
actually were our present-day narrative
is completely new I'm not gonna go into
any details about that but I can tell
you one thing you will be the
protagonist not you as a historical
employee you like all each player will
be recognized as being the protagonist
of this game okay interesting I'll have
to see more I guess keeping your lips
tightly sealed and there's been an
emphasis on co-op
obviously with the demo you guys show no
am I have a lot of people on Twitter
Roskam earlier today to sort of if you
can get some clarification around that
yeah are you are you playing
single-player most of the time and then
the co-op stuff is within missions like
almost instant space within those
missions exactly it's all within one
unified world right so the you know the
Paris is seamless there's no voting
interiors exteriors Underground's and
there's many different types of missions
you're playing for example our nose DNA
memory is his his sort of quest this is
our nose redemption story and it's a
solo experience throughout the city you
have tons of side missions this is
something that we didn't really focus on
assassin's creed before okay and we're
really doing for unity unity is really
about carving your own path through the
city that means you know discovering
your own unique mission it's about
exploring and discovering Paris you have
murder mysteries you have this is one
for us that's that's actually a murder
minute and that comes up join mission
exactly and added to quest log so you
can have multiple open quests that you
know there's obviously systemic stuff
happening like you know systemic fights
I think there's one breaking out right
there on the right the crowd and
aggressors fighting it out but you know
you have contracts you have these
treasure hunts through the city and
nastradamus we used to live in Paris as
she left these clues and you can follow
the clues to different monuments and get
rewards so the city is literally
littered with all of these different
quests and then you have what we call
Brotherhood missions these are missions
and Arno did for the assassins with
other assassins so you're doing these
missions from one to four players so you
can join up with up to three friends but
from every place respective they're
actually playing or know sort of like
watchdogs you know everybody's head in
Pierce however you know what what we are
doing is that we're letting everybody
customize our know in a way where for
example you can choose you get skill
points in the game and you can choose to
spend those skill points and buy and
upgrade skills and then you have all
these gear elements you have you know
hoods you have the actual suit you have
gauntlets gloves
you have belts you have boots and all of
these different elements actually not
only are they visually different but
they have an actual impact on game
then you have all the weapons
traditionally in a sea weapons were all
they all had the same stats yeah not
anymore also is there a straight-up
cover mechanic in this as well there is
a cover mechanic you know we have a
stealth mode that we added I mean a lot
of fans we're talking about this it's
not that we didn't want to do it before
we were just you know we wanted to do it
right yeah and so I think we actually
pulled it off stealth mode means that
you're more silent you're more precise
you know assassin screen is always
there's always this a fight between
being efficient fast and navigate
quickly through the city and being very
stealthy and precise and we're often
trying to guess what you want to do in
the game which every time we try to
guess what the player wants to do
there's an off chance that we might get
it wrong yeah which explains why
sometimes you're tailing a dude and all
of a sudden your character sticks on the
wall right by creating a specific
stealth mode we're reducing the number
of times that were actually trying to
guess what you're trying to do and that
removes a lot of those frustrating
elements I want to talk a little bit
about in a second just about the the the
motion because I'm seeing a lot of new
types of animations and the way in which
are know is actually moving around the
world first of all though just to
briefly talk to you touched on the fact
that every character is actually playing
as I know so in the co-op stuff it's
it's you're not viewing a customizable
characters aware you're actually just
viewing a cypher of each one of our know
isn't what we're doing is we're keeping
our nose unique here yeah and just
putting it we have a database of
assassins heads generic is that right no
we're just putting that head over the
body of each individual or no yeah
because we really wanted we really
wanted to keep that individual gear
because that way people can die it like
where'd you get that cool suit oh I
completed this mission and you do that
and then you can get that suit we still
wanted to showcase that like I said that
I know there's a bit of a hubbub about
you and their female protagonist stuff
but I guess yeah it's not that you're
creating your own character exact is
that it's just a cipher for someone else
exactly so yes the actual movement
integral part of the Assassin's Creed
franchise these guys started off and
with the single player dam I want to say
this one right at the top of a building
but when you descend yes
the movements the is quite different to
what we used to is is is they're my kind
of the reason for that or is it just
showing off and the protagonist his own
mentality about scaling walls it's a
little bit of both we always try to get
the our protagonists personality into
you know his spite his navigation and
Arno is a very you know very
to-the-point very sharp his movements
are more krav maga rather than kung-fu
very direct very efficient and you know
his navigation style is really a very
efficient also he doesn't wait for a you
know a haystack to do a leap of faith he
does what we call controlled ascent and
you know it was reflected by those cool
animations but there's actually a
mechanical element to it you know you
can either parkour by holding the
trigger and holding you know one button
will a cat have you parkour up the other
one like so for example you know the a
button will have you bark or up the B
button will have you parkour down you
just hold it and we'll be trying to
figure out your most efficient parkour
so you're basically trying to make it
sudden you don't put haystacks and every
single corner pockets exactly exactly
okay we're coming to the end of this
demo I you just tell us a little better
what's happening here is this very
indicative of of the assassinations in
this game because this kind of reminds
me a lot of the first game where your
you're killing somebody while I don't
know I remember specifically you killing
somebody who mounted a guillotine on a
stage at a stage just Perdita what's
what's happening here yeah it was a
little it was really were trying to sort
of a little winkin Assassin's Creed one
and show that from you know show me that
we were going back to those basics
essentially all the assassinations in
unity are in that spirit they are
open-ended so we you know we talk a lot
about the the low-level poor mechanics
of the game you know the navigation to
fight and the stealth but another thing
that we really tackled in unity is all
the mid level stuff so how you apply
those core mechanics contextually in the
world okay so the missions and you know
missions have evolved throughout the the
franchise right but we were essentially
still operating on a basis form in a
situ which was mission blocks
he had tails yeah eavesdrops you know
fight missions all that stuff what we
decided to do with unity was open it up
more so we
two large major types of mission first
RA MMS they're adapted of Mission
mechanics I'll give you an example for
so let's say your your mission your
narrative mission is to get to a secret
hideout of some bad guys right and the
way to do so is you know tale an enemy
so traditionally you would be telling
that enemy and if he spots you we D sink
yeah and then you restore if he gets too
far away it is easy right now what we
would do was this intentionally if he
spots you he will bolt and start running
becomes a chase if you lose him it
becomes a locate okay if while bolting
while running away he gets into a
systemic fight with some other NPCs and
gets killed
well then maybe if you loot the body you
find this address and you know where he
was heading but since he's now missing
they might be doubling up the guards
advance okay so we really give more
flexibility and we try to let the player
play like he wants to play our second
major improvement or innovation I should
say is blackbox design so our missions
are now our assassination missions are
and all the co-op missions are what we
call blackbox missions 360 degree
missions okay we show you a physical
space it might be an interior but it
could be an exterior and we tell you
explore find opportunities and perform
it the way you want to perform it so you
can replay at different ways sometimes
by finding side missions you might find
in you know a secret passage that leads
directly and you know shows you a
completely original way of performing
that assassination that echoes a lot of
the first Assassin's Creed game where
that's essentially what you were doing
was I was building up to that climax
actually like doing yourself I guess in
doing it this way you're not forcing
people into exactly doing all that but
the whole idea is you know I always say
this it's carving your own path through
Paris but that's really the case not
only with the side missions but even how
you perform these missions right it's
really about you know you you you spend
your skill points on are know the way
you want to do it you you get the gear
that you want to sort of reinforce the
way you already play the game and then
the game permits you to play it that way
and so you're leaning quite heavily into
the co-op stuff at this time around are
you going to have multiplayer at all as
a separate thing I know there was like
there was terror defense as well it was
applied to one of the older games and or
is it is it purely single-player with
their co-op stuff no so it is purely a
unified world so there's no second game
with with another mechanic
and we do have an element's a really
cool element in the game about it
resembles more the stuff that we had in
a situ and in in Brotherhood with the
villa where you do have stuff that you
can perform in the city that will change
the the nature of the toy district by
district that will essentially play with
again that personalization of the city
making the city your own so the stuff
that you make that you perform in the
city will actually have an impact on the
density of aggressors versus allies in
the city which will since this time
around we also embrace the toy during
missions instead of sort of switching it
off by doing that stuff you actually
have a direct impact on your missions Oh
Alex - thank you so much for coming on
Thank You fader of director of
Assassin's Creed unity and lastly just
tell the folks at home winner beds we're
gonna see us October 28th for ps4 Xbox
one and PC awesome thanks again for
coming on the games you out stage I will
be back in a couple of minutes with the
crew Ubisoft all up in this place